in September this year 2012 there was
quite an exciting piece of news about
element 113 we've been a bit slow
catching up with it so please forgive us
but the important thing is that element
113 has been synthesized in fact for the
third time and therefore people are now
reasonably confident that it has been
made like mostly elements in this part
of the periodic table the experiment
involves accelerating a light element
the nucleus of a light element that very
high speeds but tenth of the speed of
light and crashing it into a target of a
heavier element in this case it was zinc
which has atomic number 30 and bismuth
that has atomic number 83 30 plus 83
makes 113 so you imagine that there are
hundreds of these or millions and
millions of these hitting the targets
and every so often one of them goes
inside you can say it's quite hard to
achieve
so did you get a joint nucleus does it
make that noise when it happens no I
don't think so and then you know if my
dogs gonna go crazy when I so we now
have a nucleus of 113 the nucleus is
quite unstable so short time afterwards
out from the other side will come some
sort of particle probably nucleus of
helium at an alpha particle and it
decays to a whole chain of other atoms
now from my point of view the thing
that's really exciting is that this
element was made this experiment that's
just been published was done in Japan I
have here a Japanese periodic table it's
no different from the other periodic
table and down here we have element 113
there is a Japanese flag what's exciting
for me is that it's a wonderful
demonstration about how psy
is now being done all over the world
this is the first element at least in
modern times that has been discovered in
Asia I'm quite excited because there
aren't any elements with the symbol
contains the letter J though in some
early periodic tables in German they put
iodine with a jade because the German
word for iodine begins with a J so I'm
quite excited that perhaps we might have
a an element with a symbol JP or
something like that which would be real
first the day after the paper was
published I was at a reception in London
where the Japanese ambassador to the UK
was one of the guests and I was
introduced to him and I began by
congratulating him on the synthesis of
element 113 he looked a bit surprised I
think it's the first time anybody had
ever congratulated him about anything
chemical but then he got really quite
excited katashi nice I'm German and na
karoti
tottemo exciting news Akari master
Saraiva came to Bangor yakusan again
tony country happiest I'm sorry de
kochiya kuraha person